hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to untilled on now
we're gonna finish this up all in one
episode no matter what so as long as
this takes we're gonna keep doing what
we need to do did I check over here to
make sure get out of my way Mike you
dick okay there's nothing over here
absolutely nothing okay so we're gonna
venture forth who here try to find Josh
and then hopefully Oh
who the hell was that whose head was
that whose head was that Oh exact oh
okay I got you
bodies I only see one a lot of them I
only see one ah okay so is that guy's
head all right I'm assuming this this is
where all the friends would be Hayden
yeah I'm assuming if there were more
dead friends they would all be up there
and that's why she screamed no you
didn't really know that Oh
I want more Josh sequence now I'd like
to us discuss he had a really
interesting perspective huh okay okay I
trust you I trust you I trust you
whew this is gonna get interesting
hey shipping of something Josh Mike
Josh yeah hey welcome to the waking
world hit me please please what you
would be better man full mental jacket
we didn't think we'd get you back Josh
Hannah was down here weeks a month she
dug us out Mike let's just get the [ __ ]
out of here okay Josh do you have the
key for the cable car oh yeah yeah good
okay cool
see that over there that means there's a
direct way out come on come on Josh now
I like Tosh I feel bad for going beyond
poor Josh you help me up I go back to
tell the others were okay yeah yeah good
you bring Josh back the way we came and
walked up to lunch be careful oh boy
yeah more splitting up I love to split
up okay quick time events okay never
mind
Oh okay fine then all right I guess
Sam's is gonna make it on her whole I
playing Josh oh boy Luka Josh I have no
idea what his stats are now are those
really in stats is he that charitable
really honest really really okay fine
all right whatever
all right Mike still doesn't know that
Jessica's alive but I guess he knows
that Josh didn't do that at least now
anyway
gonna have to hit me so much man ah yeah
I'm sorry about before man I thought you
killed yes ah yeah you're wrong we're
all Bros now I didn't need to make sure
I get all the things I need too bad I'm
slow I did fall down a John home
probably broke a lot of bones all right
so this is one of three left what do we
got here hello oh I don't know what that
meant there's a Wendigo right in front
of Sam but there was someone behind hang
on let me see that again
one's more blazed
oh that's right it's based on movement
that's right okay so if if we ever get
to that point we're supposed to not move
a whole lot of not moving okay
that's right all righty then okay good
to know good to know good to know okay
anything else anything else we might
miss could be very easy I don't know how
much game left is there I mean I'm
pretty sure there's enough for a full
episode here but if we even if we run on
longer I don't care I want to finish
this on offenses right here and now and
we hopefully do it right I don't know
why she didn't tell exec no no no no no
no no no what no what no no who don't
know who know know who know Nino no
maybe I missed one on the way up here I
have no idea I'm just trying to keep an
eye out as best I can as best I can all
right I don't assume they would put in
some sort of artificial construct that
would prevent me from going where I
needed to go Mike
Mike what are you doing Mike Mike yo
Mike am I supposed to talk to you Mike
let me go talk to him let me see if he
needs to talk to me Mike Mikey boy don't
mind me Mike Mike
oh oh now you're going oh really really
Mike really Mike you're just waiting for
me okay thanks Mike you're a doll love
you buddy love you bros if glad we're on
good terms now sorry about Jessica but
she's gonna come back probably
okay I don't know where Matt comes back
but I'm assuming at some point he's
gonna rejoin the others I mean if we're
on the minds and was there nothing over
there must have been something hang on
just trying to be thorough guys this
gotta be thorough okay I think we're
good I think we're good
okay all right
I wonder what would happen if Josh went
over to Anna's Journal okay all right I
know there was a window gay go in here
somewhere
a Winnebago when daggoo okay oh but ANCA
that ain't good that ain't good Mike
Mike Mike Mike Mike Mike Mike Mike Mike
Mike Mike Mike Oh Mike what happened to
Mike Oh what was he doing with the
throat there oh I'm so such a coward
okay fine then be that way so that's not
oh there's Matt Oh Maddy poos still here
okay good he get a gumdrop
I didn't even have a choice there so
it's nothing I could have done
differently that would have affected
that outcome looks like Hanna being a
way to go isn't as mean as the other
ones the other ones all seem like
vengeful sons [ __ ] nice till he has a
flare gun but I don't know if he has any
actual flares with him cuz he fired it
off like a goober Kurt okay there we go
it's the only one that actually didn't
light on fire whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa that would have taken my friggin
head off
jeez Jess how are you doing Jess [ __ ]
are you still alive yeah
yeah wait pan let's see
inform or do the do boobie goddamn that
doesn't make any sense why was she just
gonna hit him that doesn't make any
sense I guess as far as she knows she
doesn't know that it wasn't actually a
monster that got her could have been
anything I don't know I'm pretty sure
she knows it was a monster okay
anyway let's see uh what happened how
did you end up down here hi can I move
it we were messing around and then it
was what I don't know I was by the
window and there was all this glass and
it was in the snow and then it was
please fast
I was um Tony come on dress alright come
on just this don't hit me with anything
Jesus that was a really sharp shovel - I
bet that would have taken bats head
right off
Oh somehow he would is op dead okay and
it just would have been like oh no okay
I don't don't know so today what are you
doing
what you guys doing I don't like that
that better be you breathing Jess better
be you breathin alright so where am I
supposed to go are there multiple paths
here there's things I could do there
seems to be an elevator right there but
there's also like light over there oh
gosh I bet the elevators out but there
might be something on the elevator that
I need you I don't like any of this all
they seem like bad choices
who is that something on the elevator
that I need it is it exactly is that
some sort of clave in here
oh I fell serious that roof you fell
this far Jesus makes two of us I thought
I forgot them fire tower down here huh
just doesn't seem okay she probably has
some minor blame blame Babbage she seems
a little woozy you didn't eat any human
flesh on the way down here did you just
just just by chance - the chance partake
some delicious human leg leg of man
anywhere ok ok
alrighty then suspicious very suspicious
aha here we go knew there would be
something all right there's a second the
last one I'll be glad when I don't have
to hunt these thing down anymore look
out one more come home well okay what
okay did that help me I don't know
Mike's been blown up enough one of these
Sam's gonna get to him okay so nothing
over here those sounds ain't good but
I'm pretty sure there's the same sounds
that Emily was encountering over in her
excursion into the mines oh I don't want
to miss anything
alright I think we're good okay I think
we're good alright
something's gonna stab me up the blood I
know it I'm gonna get quick I'm just
ready for QuickTime events because I
know they're probably gonna be coming at
any minute now yep oh here they come
QuickTime event O's or anything else
there's only one more Cho Tam I don't
want to miss it
Jessica good you oh boy okay oh wait a
minute wait a minute wait a minute wait
a minute just can't run running would be
a bad idea we need to hide cuz it's
based on movement that wasn't anything
here I got it
okay I didn't see anything that's
suggested updated what's that mean
updated what do you mean updated oh the
one to go in the mine I had an identical
butterfly tattoo okay that makes sense
okay yeah what a butter folk' so we're
gonna hide hide okay now moving down
with lunches
how's this hurt all right we got to do
this get out of here come on don't like
it I don't like this I don't like this I
don't like this I don't like this I
don't like this come on bad bad bad bad
bad I don't like it
Jess Jess come on
together hiding together hide together
hide together come on baby
don't know Bandon Jessica oh you dick
you potentially he wasn't a dick but it
was potentially he could have done whoa
whoa hey it's almost done
all right cool we're almost out of here
Oh God are we going right into quick
times hope not man she is probably tired
all right come on see mass jump we've
been doing a whole game might as well
now yeah I know
whoop okay
whoop okay see wait no grab up grab
overhang you got it whoa baby you got it
you got a baby really dangerous whoa hey
there we go really really really
dangerous oh hey god damn triki triki
triki triki triki SSX tricky okay oh god
I hate those goddamn cuz at this point I
would have to go so far to be able to do
this again oh man
okay and there's some new stuff here let
me just okay Jessica survived until dawn
wait Jessica survived until dawn does
that mean she's alive forever no okay
Josh heard the truth about the monster
Josh recognized Hannah and Hannah
recognized Josh really is that what's
happened oh I didn't know that's what
how that went okay save yourself Matt
found Jessica and survived until done
yay man made it oh boy people are
starting to make it this is crazy I
didn't know if he'd get to this point
Oh God dad's gonna be even more
stressful uh I have no idea okay eeny
meeny miny okay seems like the left path
leads all the way down I'm just trying
to find the last one here Oh God
oh boy oh boy oh boy oh boy come on Oh
does this loop around
Oh were they both oh they were both of
the same okay number and then okay
anything here let me just since it seems
like they were both same I just want to
make sure I just want to make sure right
okay all right I don't see anything
I see nothing down there
okay how about over here okay this seems
like a dead end so maybe it's over here
oh good
am I going towards the noise cuz it's
bad it's bad for me
oh okay here we go here we go here we go
okay alrighty then hmm whoa that is a
Wendigo in the house that's a Wendigo in
the wrong place okay so that's all of
them
that's all of them I did it all the
events of the past are here all right
let's watch the events of the past you
want to watch it all I was watching them
many years ago my grandfather hunted
those possessed by the curse but there
was one and eluded him the fiercest of
all the Maccabees
it was a terrible thing and my
grandfather could not defeat it sometime
after the prospectors came to mine this
mountain until a cave-in trapped them in
and woke the curse again nor dozens of
men no food no life and that blackness
the hunger they were consumed by their
abominable cravings and driven mad
Margaret cattle
you move flat
and if you kill this mantra ste the
spirit is released and swirls the
mountain like an evil wind waiting to
possess again you best not kill him
higher try you can only trap them taunt
them with fire after all these years
after many moons and many hunts the
Makah pichu still roamed free out of my
grasp
beyond my reach until one night a year
ago I was finally able to get him in my
sights
we were not alone that night I was
tracking the methyl-p queue
it was tracking something else
Michael Keaton course your friends over
the mouth there was nothing I could do I
couldn't save your friends
I could avenge them
I hunted
down and I doused it with fire
I'm a Capuchin worth
oh okay good great good job man you did
it you did it
weird how these people live does family
for a while
play baseball in the summers and stuff
maybe they were not this large the OL
time never mind I have no idea what I'm
talking about okay all right
oh gosh all right here we go I cannot
[ __ ] up
I just cannot oh that's not good all
right so there's no more collectibles to
be had I literally have everything so
now I can it's just a straight shot to
the finish I believe oh don't screw
anything up please dear God don't screw
anything up oh god hyper-vigilant mode
engaged
my blinking is gonna be the death of me
I know this I know this drop down what
is that a lake oh god it's so horrible
I don't want to do that oh boy you know
yeah yep yeah it's cold
I don't like that sound I don't like
that sound weird breathing happening
where your breathing better go better go
better go or hide I don't know it's kind
of cold is hmm okay okay we got it we
got okay we're good I guess
oh I don't like this okay
all right almost there a little farther
little farther a little farther wait
what's that over there
Oh something over there well never mind
it was nothing okay there's literally
nothing else to get so I'm just gonna go
straight to the end I'm ready to hide
I'm ready to push buttons anything and
everything anything and everything
anything and everything anything and
anything and everything okay what is
this hmm all right here we go ready Oh
got it okay no no all right we're fine
we're fine we're fine
oh just a little bit of butt blasts on
some rocks never hurt nobody oh oh oh
look
okay all right where you got it started
okay we're good
ready ready ready
poby
hey come on open up guys come on you in
there
hey Sam oh hi god you're terrible you
look worse if we stay out here come on
okay okay good good job cool
now gonna like it it's okay it's cool
Mike what happened to Josh I got him
god-awful way to go wait noxee yeah not
good not a good idea I should check the
basement
I hear someone left down there where is
everyone else yeah where is everyone
else I have no idea okay hang on one
second here they did it edited I don't I
just drive just pausing to give myself a
break you got it you got you gotta go
easy on me I just I I'm stressed I'm
very stressed oh boy
alright so down to the basement we go I
guess oh geez
yeah there's literally no nothing else
to collect so this is it this is it this
is it baby unless okay I think is it
okay here we go
how do you rate our chances of survival
mm-hmm I'm trying not to think about it
good good that bought some time good oh
oh that was so close
wait what am i doing oh yeah
wait oh boy oh boy
hey maybe I don't do anything no I don't
know what I need to do
Oh God tell me help me help you know
maybe I do nothing so I'm not about to
do nothing
Mike's not moving so you know oh man
Oh my instinct is telling me don't do
anything saving Mike how am I gonna save
Mike how would I save Mike how would I
save Mike it looks just like this in
which nothing's happening nothing's
happening
we're not doing anything
I want to say do nothing that's what I
want to say I really want to do nothing
here oh I want to look at the
walkthrough but that would be cheating
oh man running the light would be a bad
idea because I'd be running saving Josh
he doesn't need saving he's not moving
it looks just like this I think I do
nothing that's my guess if I'm wrong
this is the choice I live with this is a
choice I've made
I have no assistance on this one I just
have all these totems I am going to do
absolutely nothing
Oh God
oh my god come on oh come on no no no
and oh no no yeah ah yes
okay okay all right oh god I'm so happy
oh man oh you're no idea I restarted my
playstation ha ha ha oh man oh wow oh
man oh I'm so happy
oh God how was I to know it's like the
evidence could be interpretated in such
a way you know yeah okay now I'm gonna
save you Mike yeah
you know lucky me know like hide okay
okay huh Oh God Oh God so scared oh that
one's an ugly one hide of course
goddamnit
some
Oh
ah
oh oh so happy but said I happy oh man
oh wow
oh man ah the old man yeah what is this
I don't have to describe you said you
thought he's stalking at first did
everyone else in the group make that
oh yeah is it possible brain couldn't
kill them what no no you don't
understand don't you understand he'll
talk to you he saved my life
and I watched him die
I heard Jessica I don't know how or why
she was down there but I know I heard
her
he held it right up to my face right
here right in front of my nose and he
could have shot me he almost shot me the
prick I mean you go out with a guy for
however long and you think you know him
but man this one really takes the cake
really that's your main concern here
right there and I could have done
something I tried to do something it
wasn't good enough
how did you end up in the minds
was
carried and taken and what did you see
I don't know I don't I don't know he's
out of his [ __ ] mind
you wanted to hurt us Hey and
I thought it was one who attacked Jess I
thought were close after his sister's
disappearance and talked to me he said I
was the only one who understood him
I saw it
that's how we had a connection if you
need someone to talk to and fine
sometimes after a traumatic experience I
said I'm fine I bet that's what Josh
said to I stabbed him and I tried to get
away but I didn't know I swear I didn't
know didn't know who did you stab oh I
stabbed the maniac I didn't know it was
Josh but then he was the second house it
was no Josh had all the saws and a gun
and oh my god where's Matt is he ok are
they done looking at him I'm just a
little worried because I'm his
girlfriend did he tell you that I mean I
probably wasn't his favorite person
there for a couple minutes but he knows
how devoted I am to him he knows he said
he knows right that's weird
your friend Ashley she told us she tried
to help you she said she heard you
calling out about me what do you
remember
he came for me he did came for you where
is he did he make it you need to listen
to me I don't care if you believe me or
not
does it matter because you will you need
to go down to the mines what's in the
mine Sam
I've seen what's down there not give
anything done see it
god damn it was like the emotions went
out of her face
she's been through a lot I had a feeling
like she was gonna be like the main
character but where's Josh like that's
the big question here where's Josh he
was dragged away he wasn't like super
killed it even said in the thing it even
said it even said that he was like
recognized by the Hannah Windigo and
then hit oh here we go here we go here
we go here we go oh oh oh oh no
Oh survival one survivor ah that's what
happened butterflies hat got updated
okay
Oh Oh Oh God after hours like I was so
heartbroken after that last choice cuz
it was like well I didn't know that it
was gonna be so explicitly obvious save
my I would have saved Mike if I thought
it wouldn't have gotten me killed God I
thought oh man man this is like you can
take certain pieces of evidence and you
can look at it the right way oh good I'm
so happy I'm so happy oh I did oh god I
feel accomplished woo boy okay so thank
you everybody so much for joining me for
until done I'll give my opinion of it
right now the whole butterfly effect
thing is really cool but the outcome
wasn't as branching as I thought it
could be it's kind of a cheap way to go
for a butterfly effect when the set
pieces are all the same the set pieces
are exactly the same but the people in
them change like that's the cheap way to
do something that has a branching story
in reality when you have a branching
story it's like things change completely
and they vary wildly not just for like
oh this connects to here and this
connects to here like that ole mechanic
that kind of touted it up way more than
it actually was but that doesn't mean
the game was bad it had some great
moments that weren't exactly a game you
know you know what I mean you know I'm
saying this game was a lot like you know
heavy rain and stuff so it's more of a
engaging movie than it is an actual game
not that it's bad because there are some
really creepy things like dr. hill I
love that that was great everything to
do with Josh was fantastic even though I
didn't trust him in the beginning I
obviously picked up the D was the psycho
right away but
de Deus jaws was like the most creative
cool things in this looked a time when
you could see inside his mind and what
he sees and the ending makes sense
the reason Josh was eating that thing
because he recognized Hanna Hanna
recognized him he wanted to be with
Hanna
so he wanted to become a Wendigo so like
he wanted to be with Hanna forever
because that's what he always wanted in
his mind that's what was correct so
that's why he did that and that's why
that happened otherwise the Hanna would
have just killed him but it was so
interesting to see it was so interesting
like I really really enjoyed it
throughout the time that I was playing
it but at the same time like gameplay
wise it was very lacking of course it
was extremely lacking on gameplay it
wasn't like the most fun game but as an
experience like going through a haunted
house style type game it was great I had
a great time like it was a fun
experience and I hope you guys had a fun
time too like for some reason I either
like I'm totally okay with messing up or
I take I take something or it goes long
enough until I take something personally
I'm like what oh you think you're better
than me huh game I'll show you and so
then I want to like I want to like show
it how but how persistent and stupid I
am that's what I wanted really hope you
enjoy this thank you everybody so much
for watching thank you for sticking with
me through all my bad choices and good
choices and as always I will see you in
the next video